[Music]
the new Fox drama nine-one-one star in
counting written and Angela Bassett it
premieres tonight here's what we know
Cameron angela bassett lays down the law
you look official you're walking up all
that was like made you want to behave
you do you go get someone killed
Angela unleashes some serious fierceness
as officer Athena grant the series
explores the high-stakes do-or-die
decisions made by emergency first
responders I can help you please
Parenthood's beefed up Peter Krause who
plays a firefighter and Nashville's
Connie Britton plays a 911 dispatcher
operator kind Oh and one what's your
emergency
their job is so important and they feel
the stress of that but then they also
have to be able to walk away from the
job and go home the next time you screw
up it'll be your last and can you
believe Angela is 59 years old she keeps
herself in remarkable shape it was 24
years ago when she got this body to play
Tina Turner in what's love got to do
with him that was crazy it was a crazy
time you know I mean that was 15 or 16
hours of working out you know training
the dancing
[Music]
that's what that to you mm-hmm well yeah
but thankfully we don't have to live
that luck yeah
[Music]
you